il y a 8 mois Louis Martin qui était son
domicile de la bosse pour joindre le
convoi dit de la liberté pour dénoncer
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
travailleurs qui traversaient la
frontière américaine
il s'agissait de sa première
manifestation à vie nous l'avions
rencontré alors qu'il prenait la route
vers la capitale c'est parti avec tes
oreilles là je pense à ce moment-là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a finalement stationné son camion
devant le Parlement
jusqu'à l'assaut finale des policiers
trois semaines plus tard encore aussi
les deux
filles qui restait soit des gens dedans
qu'on s'est fait dire qu'il voulait
vérifier aussi s'il y avait des armes
fait que les ports
m'amener si vous avez plus que votre
chance de vous en avez je veux dire
mais c'est on peut pour faire l'histoire
la commission sur l'état d'urgence siège
à Ottawa jusqu'au 25 novembre commission
d'enquête les représentants de la Police
provinciale de l'Ontario et de la GRC il
y a notamment mis qu'elle n'était pas
nécessaire non puisqu'il disposait
encore d'outils pour des loger les
manifestations
le gouvernement fédéral invoque la Loi
sur les mesures d'urgence qui vous
laisse et que ça finisse au plus vite
ils ont pris le moyen le plus fort pour
pour être capable de mettre fin à ça
[Musique]
ils ont pris les moyens conséquence puis
ce sont dit on vivra que les
conséquences après tout au long du siège
des camionnettes des avocats les
conseillers leur assurant qu'ils étaient
dans leur droit d'occuper le
centre-ville de la capitale il vous
donnait même des la documentation à
mettre dans vos pare-brise avez-vous été
mal conseillé oui et non parce que
moi pour avoir parlé avec des avocats il
était un peu ambiguë envers la Loi sur
les mesures de guerre je comprends mais
à ce moment-là il vous donnait de la
paperasse puis vous disais mettez ça
dans votre pare-brise puis vous avez le
droit d'être là c'est ce qu'on vous
disait
mettons en temps normal même si la loi
des mesures de guerre est là
il reste que dans un certain
droit pareil
la Loi sur les mesures d'urgence
permettait notamment de geler les
comptes bancaires des organisateurs et
participants au convoi non moi j'ai pas
eu de conséquences par rapport à ça
toute mon dossier restait correcte mais
je sais par exemple que certaines
compagnies ont eu des répercussions avec
eux
[Musique]
le camionneur a perdu un important
contrat avec les États-Unis en raison de
son statut vaccinal même si l'on en sait
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus sur le vaccin
contre la covid-19 la position de
Monsieur Martin n'a pas changé et c'est
la liberté libre choix si tu veux y
aller les prendre les vaccins j'ai pas
de problème mais oblige moi pas le
prendre si moi je le veux pas parce que
moi dans ma tête
j'ai encore pas les effets secondaires